hey guys I'm just McDonald and it is top
five time where I throw logic out the
window and just bring you my five
favorite stories of the week let's get
going it turns out not everybody thinks
the Kinect is useless as it's currently
protecting the border between North and
South Korea it sounds like they're
actually employing modified Connect
which was sold to the korean military
last year through defense contracts as
motion sensors presently it set to alert
a local outpost if it detects people
crossing the border and it can detect
the difference between people and
animals which is pretty freaking
important if it's going to be going off
whenever it's crossed in other
completely different xboxing news you
might be able to get a cheaper xbox one
without having to trade in your old
console pretty cool a flurry of rumors
and leaks corroborated by a senior
source to VG 24-7 have suggested that a
399 dollar Xbox one model could be on
the horizon for this year however this
news did come out in the same period as
other Microsoft rumours including halo 5
impending release and the announcement
of a halo 2 anniversary edition later
this year so take it with a grain of
salt the gaming world was seriously
confused this week when the principal
watch dogs trademark was dropped but you
know who was more confused Ubisoft it
seemed pretty denim strange that UV
would decide to drop their principal
trademark on the highly anticipated
title and so it should have because it
was all the work of a prankster the
prankster filed the request for express
abandonment of the trademark under the
name of UV CEO eats Guillermo and even
forged his signature to what end
trolling I guess you we have already had
it reinstated after the drama of earlier
this week let me know if you got a
theory for why you think the pranks that
wanted to take down the Ubisoft
trademark
Kaname has come under fire this week
after confirming that the campaign for
metal gear solid ground zeroes is only
going to be two hours long gamers are a
little miffed about the prospect of
paying around 30 bucks for such a short
game even though it is a prelude to the
much meteor phantom pain the series
creator himself today Okajima waiting on
the situation saying that he thinks
gamers will be satisfied according to
kajima this is because unlike previous
Metal Gear titles the game is nonlinear
so it will facilitate multiple
playthroughs the game will consist of
five side missions alongside the main
story as well as the competitive element
last up the dreaded game delay has
reared its ugly head again and this time
it's come down on titanfall the xbox 360
version is currently the only platform
affected and for gamers who were holding
out for this version you won't be too
hard done by because the delay is only
set to put the release at two weeks past
the planned date of March 11 EA have
said the delay is necessary so the point
to the developer who are taking care of
titanfall on the 360 can put the final
finishing touches on the game are you
disappointed by the delay and which
platform will you be getting titanfall
on if you're so inclined you can let me
know either in the comments down below
or on my Twitter where I'm at just
McDonald this week on sites Danny
convinces you to take a good look at a
goat simulator I give you a list of
awesome female game protagonists in the
gist and GT Diaries gets their top gear
on that's it from me this week but we
should let me know what your favorite
stories have been and have an excellent
weekend